i think a trade's still potentially on
the table for gilmore i would imagine so
i mean
there's got to be a team out there
that's going to reassess here and go you
know we can really use something at that
position to help out
he's a really good football player and
yeah i would imagine i think if you made
me bet mike that's kind of where i would
go to
i don't see new england i i guess really
seeing him extending him in any like
extravagant way to make him like
towards the top of the league corner as
far as pay is concerned
again uh i i would i would i'm gonna bet
that
you're right i'm gonna say there's a
trade that goes down sometime between
now
and midway through training camp and
stefan gilbert is no longer with the
patriots
um so where would he go that's really
the question and let's
let's set aside the jalen ramsay madden
franchise yeah
right once every big name player who's
available yeah to come to a team that
has already collected so many big name
players they don't have any money left
or draft picks to go out and do those
deals
so other than the rams where where would
you be
watching a team to maybe spring up to
try to get stephon gilmore
like i first one i would think of is
like the raiders
having like all those young corners they
have defensive issues
those type of things they could use
somebody like that with a little veteran
leadership teach some of these young
guys see where their goes that defense
has been a struggle there
you know i did think originally of the
tennessee titans but like they got the
draft pick januris jenkins
everything like that so i think that's
one that's kind of off the table there
you know i don't know if the houston
texans will be involved in that but nick
casario knows what kind of player
stefan gilmour is but i can't imagine
them wanting to spend money like that
you know when it comes down to uh a team
that's rebuilding
so then you get into like the contending
teams and everything like that there
you know like new orleans we know there
might be a need for corner there but can
they pay him
so i i really don't know there's no team
that is just
glaring to me as i sit here and go
they're desperate they could really use
the man-to-man corner right now
right this moment because i don't think
you're a team that's like in rebuild
mode that's going to want a guy like
stephon gilmore who's kind of towards
the end of his career yet we're going to
pay him big money
uh and that's where it's interesting
indianapolis colts would they think
about it
i don't know i mean to me they could use
another corner in the mix too that's
been an issue with their football team
in my opinion
uh but that's some of the ones that at
least jump uh jump out to me mike
older player who clearly wants to be
paid now
right the titans are going to get away
apparently
with one year of julio jones without
having to cut him a gigantic
check yeah i think they're good i think
that they're not going to have to pay
him now
you get stefan gilmore you got to pay
him on his way through the door right
because he's just
he he doesn't want to trade just to say
i'm playing for a different team
and still making 7 million he wants to
trade because he's playing for a team
that's going to give him the contract
that he thinks
he deserves and remember he got a market
value deal when he became a free agent
we're like oh is he going to the bears
where is he going all of a sudden the
patriots swoop in and sign him like holy
crap they never do that
but this is the back end of that deal
the market has changed and
he wants something that reflects where
the market currently is he's 30 years
old to be 31 on september 19.
i just that's that's where it becomes
that's where it's supposed to go
yeah exactly you don't want to pay the
guy a bunch of money for the years where
he starts to descend
yeah i agreed i mean he's it's at the
point of the career where i think if
you're a gm or a coach you want like
a two or a three year deal and then you
reassess
you know i think that's the way to go i
mean would the cowboys get involved in
that conversation
you know i don't know i mean they
certainly could use it but again they
play that seattle scheme where it's not
always man-to-man
it's such a big thing seattle the same
way i could go hey they need a corner
there's no doubt about it
but i don't know if they really value
corners that way because of
you know the amount of zone they play
and that's where it just you know
with the bills get involved in another
conversation with with stefan gilmour
and thinking about bringing him back
i don't know i really don't um it's
going to be interesting to watch because
yeah it's a guy that's kind of towards
the end of his prime but still real good
and certainly underpaid for where he is
right now
uh and i just don't see new england
budging on this one to pay him big time
money
be fascinating to see him go back to the
bills the team that made him a first
round pick in 2012 where he played for
five years before going to new england
yeah and and i would i would like to
think that belichick would not want to
trade him
in the division or in the conference if
he still thinks he can play at a high
level
but if you think you're fleecing someone
for a guy that you've seen
signs that it's starting to slip
then yeah maybe you do it yeah maybe
trade them to the dolphins
maybe not that the dolphins need they
don't need it they don't they got xavier
howard and byron jones
yeah and that would be around the corner
yeah there aren't a lot of spots out
there
right where there are guys who have been
in the
new england hive who know what gilmore
can do
and could then become trade partners
there really aren't if if matt patricia
was still in detroit
i know that would make sense exactly
he's back in the building right right i
you know you're you're right and well
the new england
tree for the most part you know the
tennessee the miami
they got corners because that's what
they believe in so they went out and got
them and they made sure they got it
because that's how bill
taught their team i mean houston again
is the team that would be in that cocoon
that we would know about that might have
some knowledge about it
but you know with their current status
and like we talked about i just don't
imagine them
like trading away assets and then peeing
paying big money to a guy
where it's like well our team's not even
close to being anywhere near competitive
for like another year or two
so that that's where i don't see that
happening it's i mean i really didn't
sit here and think about and come
prepared as you could tell for teams
that might be interested totally here
and i i it is it's hard to find one that
just really pops to you
to where you go that makes a lot of
sense maybe it is a dallas cowboys type
of move the more i sit here and think
about it
to where they just let me throw one out
yeah let me throw it out that i just
thought of the team that has been
sneaky chasing big name players who are
on
the wrong side of 30 arizona whether
it's j.j waters
or aj green yeah stefan gilmore to the
cardinals they lost patrick peterson
uh-huh
in free agency um i like that one that
would make sense
that makes a lot of sense i i agree with
you you're on to something there that
that could make sense
and they're like they're right there
they're kind of ready
like this is the kind of thing that oh
maybe gets you over the hump now to
where you go well no they're a legit
playoff team they were kind of teetering
on the edge we don't really know
but now you get a guy like that yeah
that could be a difference-making move
for that football team
and one that you know for for where they
at in their franchise it makes sense
like that's one that makes sense for
them
uh at this current state uh point in
time
i just had a vision yeah kyler murray
with his a's hat on
baseball glove you know how you like to
just throw the ball into the glove
walking into steve kim's office
hey steve what do you think about stefan
gilmore steve you're such a steve he's
available steve
you're trying to get a winning team here
steve do you like my ace hat you like my
age
power play him with baseball gear that's
what you're going to do
yeah exactly yeah i can't see that yes
just walking around you know throwing
the ball in love i never understood why
people did that but when i was a kid i
did that too i guess if you don't have
anybody have a catch with you just throw
the ball into the glove and see that or
carry the glove
it feels around with the ball and there
he goes he's stirring the pot baby
here we go he want to trade or we're
going to play baseball
what's in that pot is that some sort of
jambalaya i don't know it looks like it
might be beef stew or something like
that either way i'm not eating it if
you're cooking it
i ain't eating it well
you know you know yeah for you uh chef
specially made it for you
so absolutely you're good for anybody
else would be fine
um yeah it depends yeah so there would
be certain circumstances where you would
eat it no matter whether or not i cooked
it usually on a thursday night at about
10 30 p.m
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports